we were created as communal beings as
familial beings to give of ourselves to
actually sacrifice to have some kind of
commitment and I just hope there are
women who can wake up and realize you
know I'm not enough I don't have it all
in myself to make sure that I'm
fulfilled and satisfied I actually have
to give of myself in order to do that
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special with our
special guest Allie Stuckey we're going
to get to questions for the conservative
millennial and the host of relatable
over a blazed TV in just a second but
first can you believe that it's already
April time has a habit of getting away
but if you've got a mortgage or kids or
anyone depending on your income you're
gonna have to spend some of that
precious time getting life insurance if
you need life insurance but you don't
want to spend a lot of time comparing it
you should give policy genius a try
policy genius is the easy way to buy
life insurance online in just two
minutes you can compare quotes from the
top insurers and find your best price
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and red
tape no Commission's no hidden fees just
more time saved for you and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they also make it easy to find the
right home insurance auto insurance or
disability insurance they're your
one-stop-shop for financial protection
so if you need life insurance but you're
short on time head on over to policy
genius calm and comparequotes policy
genius is easy it saves you money not to
belabor the point but it's fast policy
genius spend less time comparing life
insurance more time doing literally
anything else being responsible adults
make sure that your family is taken care
of in case god forbid you should plot
make sure that you do the responsible
thing go get some life insurance right
now over at policy genius calm once more
that is policy genius calm or you can
compare life insurance and save yourself
some time and money well Ali thanks so
much for joining the show really
appreciate it yeah thanks for having me
so I think that this makes you the
fourth woman we've ever had on the show
out of some 40 yes so we're doing great
and the first pregnant woman right the
first time I interviewed two people at
once yeah you know how she does yeah
exactly well if she keeps her mouth shut
it'll be fine okay okay so what are you
do
I'm doing G own the end of June so got a
little bit of time and obviously already
know the sex of the baby yes the girl
although we can't actually judge its
gender one or two choices just a girl
yeah okay but I don't want to be
cisgender so we don't want to assume the
sex of the baby even if you know it's
probably gonna be safe to assume I'm
just gonna go ahead and put that on her
okay it's a girl okay yeah I'm not gonna
give her that option
good to know so how are you feeling I
mean this is a first baby so how are you
feeling about all this are you in the
impatient phase yet just get it out
phase kind of I mean you remember I'm
sure your wife was pregnant twice once
you get in the third trimester where I
am now you're just like okay I'm huge
I'm uncomfortable I'm so ready to be
done with it
even quite there yet I'm only 28 weeks
and so it's when you get into that like
35 and beyond that you're like I am done
being pregnant but it's good obviously
it's a blessing and I'm enjoying it I
mean the good news is that it's not a
baby yet right I mean like it's not a
been told it's not a baby until it's
like five just like this club it's so
weird because I actually feel her moving
around but I'm trying to reconcile that
with the idea that she's just this blob
of tissues it's it's crazy how that
happens though so you're the host of the
show called relatable for folks and go
check it out over at Blais TV and you
have been in the headlines a lot over
the last couple of years particularly
for having a thing called sense of humor
which I believe the left has near made
illegal at this point yes they've
completely killed it and well one of
your most famous non humorous bits it
was not satire I was informed it was
just fake videos bad editing was you
making fun of Alexander Ocasio Cortese
yes which was really easy to do because
all we had to do was take things that
she actually said and ask her questions
and make her answer them to show hey
this lady doesn't actually know very
much and so we didn't even have to
satirize it all that much we didn't have
to you know take her words out of
context that much we just kind of showed
hey this is who she is and what she
believes and it worked I mean I was I
was pretty amazed by the media reaction
to that because it is astonishing to me
how they suddenly forget what a sense of
humor is yes forget what a joke is like
suddenly it's the jokes don't exist
you're perfectly serious and you
deliberately cut her out of context to
make her look bad yeah not as a joke
just because you're a vicious
personality yeah it was dishonest and I
think that we all knew that I loved the
sanctimony two of them saying well we
know that it's satire but there were a
lot of people online that just didn't
know it so we need to explain this to
you that this interview that was spliced
together from a PBS interview that you
saw last week that it's not real I mean
it couldn't have been more obvious that
it was a joke I was surprised by that I
knew people wouldn't like it but I was
surprised a little bit by people
pretending not to know that it was
spliced together in a humorous way yeah
I was I was shocked by that too
especially because this has been a
typical thing that's been done comedies
not invented forever I mean didn't call
here does it on his show regularly with
President Trump where he pretends that
he's interviewing Tripp and then he cuts
it out of place it really is astonishing
so you gain a lot of notoriety based on
that what's what's life been like since
the rise of your notoriety in the last
couple of years I mean we start from
beginning how did you get to the point
where you do what you do now yeah so it
was about three and a half years ago so
fall of 2015 I was in PR and social
media I just graduated from college 2014
I lived in Athens Georgia which is a
college town swear the University of
Georgia is and I was extremely
interested in this election probably not
for the first time in general it wasn't
interested in politics for the first
time in general but this election seemed
extremely important in that our nation
was at a tipping point especially for
young people now surrounded by these
college students and surrounded by other
people my age who knew a lot and were
well educated but had no idea what we're
going what was going on in the primaries
no idea who they were going to vote for
if they were going to vote at all and I
just kind of looked around at that okay
this is this is a problem I've got all
these smart people around me and they
have no idea what their values are and
so I just kind of randomly had an idea
and called my mom one day and the fall
of 2015 and said I think that I want to
go to sororities and tell them why they
should vote in the primaries I just
think that's something that I would like
to do and so I started reaching out to
the presidents of these sororities at
the University of Georgia saying hey
I've got a nonpartisan presentation it
was nonpartisan about why you should
vote in the primaries I want to do it
for free I just want to tell you guys
why this is important and so I started
doing that and then I started getting a
bunch of emails from students saying hey
can you answer my question about this
and I just I loved it I kind of fell in
love with that idea of helping people
form their beliefs and then I kind of
ditched the nonpartisan thing pretty
quickly started the blog the
conservative millennial after a few
months of doing that and just writing
posts and then doing videos that kind of
took off at the end of 2016 the
beginning of 2017 we moved to Texas
that's when I got a job at the blaze and
that's when it kind of became a full-on
career so it was about a year and a half
of you know speaking for free writing
for free doing my own thing until I got
hired somewhere and then it turned into
a media career that I was actually doing
and I still do all of that I mean I have
a pod
now because I worked at CR TV which is
now blaze TV have a podcast they still
speak on college campuses and of course
I'm on TV commentating so I do a lot of
the same things they did in the very
beginning it's just now I do it
full-time
so you have a couple of strikes against
you and sort of being in the
conservative category you are young and
you're female which means you can
neither be young nor female if you are
conservative so how did you end up as a
young female conservative what shaped
your values yeah well my parents
definitely I don't have an interesting a
political story and that I don't have
any kind of like about-face at at which
point I said okay I once believed that I
once thought that and I don't anymore
and here's what's changed my mind I kind
of wish I had that story I think it's
interesting when people do I just don't
my parents we're poor growing up they
really came from nothing and they were
poor when they got married at 19 and 20
and they made really good choices in
their lives to make sure that my
brothers and me had a better life than
they did and when I was young they
talked to me a lot about
entrepreneurship they talked to me a lot
about the joy of being your own boss and
being able to be independent they always
told me you can do whatever you want to
do whatever dream you have if you put
your mind to it you can do it and so
they never talked to me about politics
per se I mean I knew that we were
Republicans I knew that we like George W
Bush I remember all that but they never
sat me down and said you know here's why
we're conservative or here's why we're
Republicans it was really just the
values of individual liberty of
entrepreneurship that I liked and I
never had a moment where I was like you
know what more government control
actually sounds kind of good or like
maybe maybe I don't feel like human
beings have this great potential that
they can reach on their own I never had
that and so it was really the values
that my parents instilled in me growing
up and of course being raised in a
Christian home I think has a lot to do
with that as well and so I really can
say I've always been a conservative but
probably didn't really understand why
and what that meant until I was in
college and how did you define yourself
as a conservative in college you say
sort of made yourself aware of what your
actual principles were what were the the
sort of key components of yourself
education well I think that my faith has
always kind of undergirded everything
that I believe politically and I think
that starts with the dignity of the
human being that's why I believe in the
Constitution that's why I believe in how
our country was founded
and I think being those things being
pushed against in college is what made
me realize wow not everyone believes the
things I do because I grew up in the
Bible Belt in Dallas and I went to a
Christian school kindergarten through
twelfth grade then I went to college in
South Carolina which is not a you know
not a very liberal state but went to a
liberal arts college where a lot of the
professor's probably leaned to the left
and took a lot of religion classes a lot
of rhetoric classes and a lot of
constitutional law classes and I
realized okay what I believe about the
Constitution what I believe about
individual liberty and small government
is not something that everyone believes
but I was lucky I don't know if it was
just because I I went to a good school
that I really that had a lot of good
professors or if it was just before all
the craziness happened but I had an
amazing professor who was a liberal she
taught African American rhetoric which
was one of my favorite classes and she
loved Barack Obama and she knew I was
voting for Mitt Romney but we had a lot
of conversations in her office about the
differences that we had that she was a
Christian I was a Christian she was
pro-choice I was pro-life and we could
sit down and have conversations I was
one of her favorite students she still
talks to me she was one of my favorite
professors I never felt ostracized in
her class I never felt really in any of
my classes maybe I was just ignorant but
I never felt like oh I can't believe
this or I can't talk about this I always
felt like there is an environment in
which I could discuss and debate these
things and I would say the dr. King
while I was in school really helped kind
of helped me hone what I really believed
it was the pushing against and the
debating that helped me I think make it
my own you know when I was in law school
I had a professor named Alana Guinier
who was the Under Secretary nominee for
Under Secretary of Labor under Bill
Clinton so far left she was so firm so
Marxist a Democratic Senate turned her
down and she's very much the same way
very open-minded happy to have
conversations like this I feel like
something has changed for a broad
spectrum of folks on the left where they
don't actually want to have
conversations anymore they prefer to
browbeat or attack character do you feel
like there's been a sea change and how
the Left approaches these discussions
probably I think it's very identitarian
in nature and that if you disagree with
me it's not just that you're wrong but
it's that you're a bad person and it's
also because you hate me for who I am
we can't separate ideas from people or
from the
the people who hold them and so I think
that's probably part of the vitriol I
can't say exactly why that happened
besides the eight years of identity
politics that were exacerbated by Barack
Obama and used by Barack Obama and so
there definitely has been a shift in
that but I I didn't bear the brunt of it
when I was in college and that I'm
really thankful for so with all of this
said do you think that there is a common
Center for the country right now I mean
this is what I worry about most so you
know you talked about the fact that
these discussions take place and some
people on the Left would have these
discussions with you and you talked
about the rise of identity politics one
of the things I've hear is that the
social fabric is decaying to the point
where we can't have the discussions at
all you you speak to young people all
the time do you think this is getting
worse or is this getting is there a
place where it comes back together I
think some of the depiction of college
students is can be a little bit
overblown and I obviously you know this
better than anyone there are a lot of
college students out there that do not
want to be do not want dialogue they
don't want discussion they don't want to
hear your ideas they just want to call
you a racist
but I have had a lot of interaction with
students who are on the left or in the
middle who really do want dialogue and I
do think that we need to point that out
that not every leftist student believes
that you are a racist idiot for being a
conservative they might not agree with
you but I've had a lot of respectful
students come to my talks and ask me
very respectful questions now they might
not like them I've had definitely a few
here and there that will yell during my
talks the most disrespectful students
I've ever interacted with we're at UC
Berkeley the absolute worst couldn't get
any words out without someone screaming
it was crazy was like they never heard a
conservative thought but I would say in
most places I've been there are people
on the other side who are willing to
hear you out I wish we would highlight
that more and then I also wish that we
would use those voices and and and give
platform to those kind of conversations
because they do happen okay so let's
talk about 2016 he started to rise to
prominence in 2015 2016 he started
getting really involved openly
politically what was your stance on
President Trump during the action I was
adamantly against him in the primaries I
think I probably have a position that a
lot of people did
adamantly against him in the primaries I
had family members that voted for him of
the primaries and I was like I do not
understand what you guys see in him I
mean he doesn't stand for anything that
I believe and not personally or
politically or does it seem like it
anyway especially from a Christian
perspective I'm like this guy is just
spouting his mouth and I'm just
embarrassed every time he talks how
could someone vote for him but then he
became to me the last year of two evils
I'm like okay what what do I want do I
want someone whose personality and
personal life I really hate or do I want
Hillary Clinton whose and I saw it as a
binary choice I know that you didn't in
a lot of people didn't but I did
or do I want Hillary Clinton who I feel
like is going to perpetuate some of the
worst eight years in the history of
American presidencies that we've just
had and so I said you know what I don't
know I don't know if Trump is going to
lead conservatively but I trust that
he's probably at least more likely to
surround himself by people who support
the values that I support and that will
push for the things that I believe in
more than Hillary Clinton law and so
that's why I ended up voting for him and
I would vote for him again if not only
to save country from what have become
extremely radical Democrats not even
practical Democrats but radical
Democrats and I think a lot of people
probably feel the same way
so can you assess President Trump on on
sort of his own terms let's put aside
the Democrats for a second you have to
grade him so yeah why you give him a
grade four for health how he's done so
far hmm I'm gonna give him a B+ because
I think policy-wise she's done he's done
some good things I mean he's done some
good things I probably more than a lot
of conservatives that support what he
does
I actually am bothered by his rhetoric
like I'm truly bothered by it like I
really don't like his personality I
don't like how he is on Twitter I think
a lot of people they've come to love
that maybe or they've come to just not
care about it but it really just rubs me
the wrong way so I can't give him an A
and of course the pro-life issue yes
he's been an advocate he's been
outspoken his administration has but
we're still funding Planned Parenthood
and that should have been a top priority
in my opinion so I would probably give
him a B+ I do wish he would just be
quiet now a lot of people love that like
they love that about him and they think
that I'm crazy for thinking that but I
just I really hate how he throws punches
I think it's extremely petty and
immature and I don't like it okay so
let's talk about exactly what you're
talking about I think that one of the
great problems for President Trump going
forward to 2020 is the fact that in 2018
he really lost suburban women suburban
women split really in a strong way
against him he's doing really poorly
among young people and as I say among
females particularly he's winning among
males he's losing dramatically among
females do you think that that is
something that holds going forward do
you see any any hope that he's gonna be
able to compete against a Democrat among
among women given all his personality
issues yeah I think it it largely
depends on and I hate to continue to
grade Trump against Democrats but they
make it almost impossible it's like yeah
Trump alone isn't all that great but
compared to the barbarism that we're
seeing in some portions of the left yeah
he seems pretty he seems pretty great
and so I think it depends on whether or
not women are going to be swayed by that
whether or not they're going to be
swayed by his policies whether or not
they're gonna be swayed by his actions
or if they're just gonna be a swayed by
the emotional rhetoric that he's
throwing kids in cages that he grabs
woman by the genitalia and reads his
Twitter feed and sees okay this is not
someone that I would want my kids to
look up to this is what I think a lot of
suburban moms are thinking and so why
would I vote for someone like this and I
also think that there is this attachment
to social justice particularly among
white evangelical women suburban moms
that says okay yes I used to vote
Republican because I was pro-life I
cared about abortion but now maybe
pro-life doesn't just mean abortion now
maybe pro-life means kids at the border
now maybe it also means gun legislation
now maybe also it means the
redistribution of wealth to help the
poor so you've got this expansion of
pro-life happening coming from the left
at seeping in to the evangelical female
world that I think could push people
away from Trump but then again you got
Democrats calling for literal and fanta
side so that could turn some off too so
if you look at the Democratic fields who
do you think is the most dangerous to
President Trump right now
I've said Kamala Harris for a while now
she has it I haven't really seen her in
the headlines all that much recently
just because she has the
intersectionality point and even though
she may be her background isn't
necessarily what most leftist wouldn't
like I do think because she carries
herself in such a mature way because she
carries herself is so even keeled and as
a good and strong leader and she does
have the intersectionality points I
think that she could possibly be a
strong contender but if we look at the
numbers I mean we've got Bernie Sanders
we've got Biden I think someone like
Pete Buddha judge I don't think that
he's necessarily gonna be a strong
contender but someone who says that hey
I represent real Christian values
I represent what it really means to be a
strong leader I'm also a veteran I think
people like that make Trump kind of look
petty and they they could definitely
have an effect but ultimately I just
don't know if it's possible for him to
lose at this point I don't know what so
I want to ask you about Buddha judge for
a second because in the last couple of
weeks he's made some comments
specifically about Christianity that I
as a religious person found pretty
off-putting his suggestion number one
that if you're evangelical and you
support Trump then you're obviously not
evangelical and then his suggestion also
about Mike Pence that Mike Pence was
arguing with God if he thought that
people to judge was engaged in sin I
found both those comments peculiar and
I'm putting but how prevalent are our
feelings like that in the evangelical
community do you think well it just kind
of it just kind of depends in between if
you have evangelical Protestants I think
69% of them still support President
Trump in the job he's doing
that's down but that's still a lot of
them but only about 50% of mainline
Protestants and I would include Buddha
judge in that those are people that
typically have a more liberal doctrine
and liberal theology those people about
half of them approve of Trump so I would
say among the mainline Protestants
that's probably a pretty prevalent line
of thinking that okay Trump he doesn't
represent who Christ was he doesn't
represent a peacemaker he doesn't
represent someone who turns the other
cheek when they malign him and that's
what Christ told us to do and so why
would an evangelical vote for him
but something I would say to Pete
Buddha judges well look what your party
represents and then tell me who you
think the evangelicals would really vote
for yes as we've already discussed
Trump's personality and some of the
things that he says they're not
attractive to most Christians I would
say no one looks at him and says that
man's a lot like Jesus but they look at
him defending religious liberty
defending the unborn and all the things
that we hold dear and they say okay well
that's probably better than socialism
like that's probably better than
infanticide so Buddha judge seems to not
understand that as far as the whole Mike
Pence thing I mean obviously obviously
that is it's not a crew it's just not a
correct statement you can disagree with
pentas theology on gay marriage but it's
not correct to say that pence would be
arguing with God because the Bible is
extremely clear we both agree on this
but in the Old Testament and in the New
Testament about gay marriage and about
suppressing biological urges in order to
honor God and and to do what he says to
do whether we agree with it or not and
so that again was a very theologically
misguided statement you might not agree
with Mike Pence but to say that he's
arguing with God is a little bit silly
and in that it was that exchange that
really led me to believe that there are
a lot of people on the Left who are just
upset with religion generally meaning
that it's not that they think that the
Trump is a bad representative of
Christianity it's that anybody who is on
the right is a bad representative
anything and the attacks on pence I
think it's just a reminder to a lot of
folks on the right exactly why Trump is
president yang that they did this to
Romney they did this to John McCain now
they're doing it to Mike Pence if he
weren't any Republican they'd be out
there suggesting that person was a bad
Christian even somebody like my pence
who really tries to live his faith out
yeah they're really only okay with the
Christians who who believe the parts of
the Bible that talk about helping the
poor and only if you want to help the
poor in their way only if you want the
government to actually help with the
poor so they're okay with people who
judge saying I think he said his
favorite Bible verse was whatever you do
for the least of these you do unto me
which is true that's a great Bible verse
and that's what Jesus said but he that's
an individual mandate that's an
individual command that's not a command
for the government of course we already
know that but that's what the left says
that you're not really compassionate you
don't really uphold the biblical values
of compassion unless you believe in
government can
and of course most conservatives if not
all conservatives no that's not true
okay so other candidates on the
Democratic side of the aisle having some
trouble to launch Joe Biden most
prominently yeah what do you make of the
controversy surrounding Biden and his
odd hair smelling and tasting and all
the rest of this here's my thing I don't
think that he is a sexual assault term I
don't think he's a sexual harasser but I
also don't think that his actions are
completely innocent I don't think that
he's just this old guy from a previous
generation that likes the smell of
shampoo I just don't believe that I
think that there is a little bit of
creepiness and a little bit of weirdness
and I would say a purposeful weirdness
that comes with him being overly touchy
to women in public I just think it's odd
I know that you can be a touchy person
but at some point your social cues kind
of pick up and say okay well maybe I
shouldn't smell the back of someone's
head I don't know so I don't think it's
completely innocent I do think that he's
creepy that doesn't mean that he is a
villain of the me to movement though and
yeah that does raise the opposite
question that the left is raised which
is anytime you say that somebody like
Joe Biden is creepy well what about
President Trump how do you deal with
that you know as a female conservative
how do you deal with Trump's history the
allegations that been made against him
how do you bifurcate well what I
encourage people to do if you were
against something that President Trump
did just say that it's don't try to make
an excuse for it I could say yeah I
don't like what he said in that Access
Hollywood tape and I don't like what
he's probably done with women I don't
like that he probably cheated on his
wives that doesn't make what Biden did
any better if your only argument for
someone's morality on the left is but
Trump that's not a very good argument
why not be the person that says yeah
both of them are wrong I'm not saying
that Trump is disqualified because of
those things I'm also not saying that
Biden is disqualified because of those
things I think people should make that
decision but I I don't think the but
Trump argument is a very logical one so
where do you think we stand with the
Miche movement given all of this so
there's been this attempt to expand the
me2 movement beyond sexual assault yeah
and sexual abuse to weird hair smelling
and at the same time to suggest that an
allegation is tantamount to proof of
guilt yeah so where do you think do you
think that the what started off is what
I thought was actually somewhat of a
passe
movement is now irredeemable do you
think that there are some core of it
that is that is left to to be promoted
yeah what do you think of its trajectory
I agree with you that in the beginning I
thought that it did some good and that
it gave women cover who maybe previously
were scared to talk about their stories
to come forward and say yeah this
happened to me and it was wrong and it
scared me whatever they wanted to say I
do think it's good that women feel more
confident in coming forward that they're
not only going to get shamed for it but
it turned very quickly and it was mostly
during the Kavanagh thing from listen to
her to believe her I'm all for listening
to her I want to hear her story and I
think that she deserves to be listened
to I don't think she deserves
necessarily to be believed no matter
what and so that's when when it shifted
from believe her to her to listen to her
to believe her that's kind of when we
lost all sense of logic all sense of
justice all sense of truth and I'm not
sure if there's any way to go back what
what do you think the these sort of
gradations of me to look like because
this is the other thing that's happened
is that there's two big questions I see
outstanding one is the question of
evidence you have Brett Kavanaugh
somebody makes an allegation a bunch of
people jump to he's automatically guilty
a bunch of people jump to there's no
evidence he's in a sense that's question
number one that question number two is
what is the kind of activity about which
we should be worried because the media
movement seems to me never to have
actually clarified this on the one hand
there's harvey weinstein activity which
you can everyone can sorta can see is
disgusting and then you have people who
are like well as he's on sorry the
comedian invited a woman back to his
apartment they engage in a bunch of
consensual stuff she decided later she
wasn't happy with it
yeah that's me too - well where do you
think the lines should actually lie here
yeah I certainly don't want to be the
one to set the concrete standard but I
do think Aziz Ansari is a really good
example of when it wasn't when you may
this is a decision to do something and
then you didn't like the consequences of
it which is totally fair you can tell
your story but you can't say that you
were assaulted and we do need to draw
the line there and I think something
that we need to get better at is at not
calling encouragement of personal
responsibility victim shaming like there
is wisdom that women should have should
guys be to Ford with girls after they've
told them no no should guy do guys ever
have an excuse to do something wrong to
a girl to a
Sault a girl to harass a girl absolutely
not but are there steps that girls can
take is there provision that girls can
take is there wisdom that girls can
employ absolutely and I think that the
completion of offering wisdom and
guidance to women advice to women on
personal responsibility with victim
shaming has just made the whole
conversation so stupid like you can't
even you can't talk about it you can't
talk about it at all you feel like you
can't even tell your daughter hey here
are some steps that you should take to
just be wise in your life and to avoid
bad guys because bad guys are always
going to exist you feel like you can't
talk about that because I'm will taneous
Lee you see I mean half of Instagram has
their entire butt out the entire time
and you're saying well I don't want to
be objectified well you're gonna be
objectified you're going to I'm not
saying that it's right but you're going
to and so but we're not allowed to talk
about modesty we're not allowed to talk
about any of that without them saying
well you must you know hate women be a
misogynist and blame all victims
well this is definitely a pet peeve of
mine and it's something that you can
speak to more obviously because you're a
woman
I you know where does the line lie
between as you say victim shaming and
personal responsibility taking because
if you ever have you know I have said on
the show don't get drunk and go back
with a guy back to his room yeah I just
don't do it it's a stupid thing to do
and then people say well this is you
making an excuse for a guy's like well
no that's not me making an excuse for a
guy that's me saying that if you walk
through a high crime neighborhood wave
your wallet around you get robbed that's
the fault of the person who robs you but
you're also an idiot
yeah don't put yourself in a risky
situation why do you think it is that so
many people find simple fact totems that
people give every day to their children
to suddenly be a form of victim shaming
because I think the highest value that
our culture now has is authenticity
which means doing what you want to do
that's the only value we have it's not
discipline it's not honoring God there's
no sense of shame anymore and so if your
only goal in life's just be yourself and
do what you want and be happy
then the idea of suppressing any kind of
desire that you have seems really cruel
it's not just discipline it's not just
wisdom well that's that's almost archaic
that's really mean I I don't want to do
something that I don't want to do where
I want to be able to do something that I
do want to do and so the idea of kind of
suppressing any
that we have is really unattracted in a
world in which we're told that you
shouldn't have any guilt shouldn't have
any shame you should never feel bad
about yourself we're told self love is
the most important thing that you can
have if you just wake up in the morning
and tell yourself how awesome you are
then you'll be completely fine and so
discipline and the idea of making good
choices at the expense of what you want
doesn't really fit into the idea of just
making yourself feel good all the time
and that that system I think you're
exactly right obviously and I think that
system leads to a tremendous amount of
actual unhappiness people who are at war
with reality and who think okay well
I'll just ignore reality and then if
things don't work out the way I want
then I've been somehow destroyed by the
system with all of that said let's talk
a little bit about dating advice for
young women so I have dating advice for
young women which is typically watch out
for guys guys are the worst guys are
terrible there was there's a girl when I
was at Harvard Law who had a the name of
the book she wanted to write that I
don't think she ever did but that seemed
about correct to me which was boys are
scum girls are dumb and I thought that's
a fair synopsis and at least insofar as
guys go girls are know about guys they
think that guys are generally
well-intentioned and nice and guys are
generally not well-intentioned and ice
yeah and guys are gross and take
advantage of girls all the time but
girls refuse to accept this and thus
make silly decisions about guys what is
your dating advice for for young women
yeah well it's it's all different now
that I know that I have a daughter
coming into the world because my dating
advice for myself was that I learned
from my own mistakes I mean I dated
stupid guys both in high school and
college I did learn from my mistakes and
I ended up marrying an awesome person he
was nothing like the people that I dated
before who were so stupid but now that I
have a daughter coming into the world
I'm like I really don't want you to
learn from your own mistakes I'd rather
you learn from my mistakes or other
people's mistakes I wish that I wish
that no one would date in high school
just because you're just so dumb you're
so hormonal you have no idea what you're
doing you have no idea what the idea or
anything you have no idea what a good
idea is you really don't and so wait
until your brain fully develops at least
until you're like 21 or 22 and you can
make some semblance of a good decision I
wish people would go down that road but
date someone that
shares the same values as you and that
you could actually see yourself Marianne
if you couldn't see yourself marrying
the person don't give them something
that you ultimately wish that you would
have only given to the person that you
end up marrying obviously that's archaic
advice I mean telling people to be
virgins until marriage is obviously very
scary stuff right speaking as a person
who did it
it works out well it's great guys but it
I never regret it you never regret
getting married you never get married
and say wow I wish I would have made out
with more guys like I wish I would have
woken up next to more strangers in
college no one says that but a lot of
people say I really wish I hadn't given
so much before I got married so seems
like good advice and what's your advice
for guys conversely like what should a
guy be looking for in a girl what's a
good dating strategy for for women
what's a good strategy for women or men
men with regard to okay well I would say
the same thing look for someone who
shares your values look for someone who
is respectful look for someone who you
could actually see yourself ending up
with a lot of guys I've noticed or
attracted to the crazy there's just
something about the crazy that guys like
I don't know if it's the dependency or
what it is no that's gonna be miserable
real fast she might be really cute she
might make you feel like you're needed
and one in like you're a superhero that
gets old real fast look for a girl that
can hold her own could have a real
conversation with you doesn't matter if
she wants a career or not but just
someone who thinks who knows who she is
who is confident who she is
and who can actually challenge you to be
a better person do you think that the
institution of marriage is gonna make a
comeback because obviously it's had a
pretty rough few decades here first with
enormous number of people having kids
out of wedlock but also just people
being in relationships a lot less I mean
the rise of the pornography culture the
rise of an online culture that suggests
you don't need to human companionship
people ignoring relationships in favor
of other things and that there's a there
it's been fascinating to watch the left
panic over the so-called sex gap young
people not having as much sex when they
were guaranteed to have as much free fun
consequence free sex as they could
possibly want and now they're just not
having sex they're just staying home and
watching Netflix in the absence of
relationships do you think marriage is
going to make a comeback in here
I hope so I've also hope I've told for a
resurgence of a lot of things with
Millennials being so degenerate with
going so far to the left with being so
irreligious with being so obsessed with
technology you do
under if there will be an awakening
either the younger Millennials or the
next generation of saying ok like this
isn't going well because our depression
rates are high or anxiety rates are high
we're really lonely and so maybe the
things that we're pursuing of the things
that we're doing this hyper
individualism that were so addicted to
this instant gratification that were so
addicted to maybe it's not working out
so well maybe there's a purpose bigger
than myself maybe happiness is found in
giving of myself rather than just giving
to myself there could be that I
certainly hope so I can't say I'm
necessarily optimistic but I do wonder
with all of the science that's coming
out about how harmful technology is not
that I think technology is the source of
all evil but with how harmful it is
especially to children if their will
kind of be a turning away from the hyper
individualism that I think is encouraged
by technology and attorney until family
to community to things that are
happening in a real life and I think if
that happens and there could be a change
in values so one of the things I think
that feminism is done particularly to
young women is basically lied to them
and so they could have they could have
everything and it's just not true I mean
in my opinion it is it is pretty in fact
not even opinion based it's it the
science suggests that you cannot have
all of these things there are only a
certain number of hours in the day and
yet people have been told young women
have been told you should pursue career
first you should not have kids until you
are almost out of childbearing age you
shouldn't get married until you're 30
you should you should wait as late as
possible for everything because you must
develop a career because true
fulfillment is to be found in a career
yeah I don't think that that is
ultimately fulfilling for a huge number
of women what's here what's your take on
all of this I don't think so either and
I think it goes back to again that very
popular mantra that you are enough
self-love self-care it's very thinly
veiled narcissism that you are going to
find everything you need inside yourself
and so chase that career get good
triceps make sure that you follow this
eating plan wash your face clean out
your closet until it sparks joy all of
these things that might not be bad
independently but when you look to these
self-help guides for all of your
satisfaction and fulfillment you very
quickly realize that you don't have
enough in you in order
to make you satisfied and fulfilled long
term you just don't we were created as
communal beings as familial beings to
give of ourselves to actually sacrifice
to have some kind of commitment and I do
think that unfortunately kids are seen
as this kind of accessory that they're a
burden to the rest of your life and so
they're an inconvenience if you want to
travel you need to make sure that you
travel all the countries in Europe we
here before you have kids need to make
sure that you make a certain amount of
money
well that sees kids and family as a huge
inconvenience to your life rather than
what the Bible says that they are which
is an amazing blessing and a privilege
so I think it's just a shift in
perspective and I just hope there are
women who can wake up and realize you
know I'm not enough I don't have it all
in myself to make sure that I'm
fulfilled and satisfied I actually have
to give of myself in order to do that ok
so now I have to ask you the first
question where will disagree and
apparently you're a big fan of leggings
I do I do I love like have you ever worn
them if I bet if you wore them you would
like to possibly wear like I just say
you might change your mind
I'm a married heterosexual man I don't
know okay I mean because your husband
never were like are you with me about
the leggings that of course I wouldn't
argue with my wife about her wearing
leggings either ok ok so we'll start
from a premise different clothing
conveys different things to people right
this is why we don't want to walk around
naked the closer a woman is to walking
around naked close to that at all you
are such a girl it's their pants that
are that are skin tight that is the
purpose of leggings yes okay I mean okay
am I wrong about this like there are
sweatpants my pants are baggy
I know but you can't go on a walk in
sweatpants it's too hot they are
literally called sweat pants you sweat
in them that is what they are for pants
and you don't know you look more put
together if you have leggings on then if
you have sweat pants on so if you're
going to the grocery store you want to
be comfortable and not everyone likes
how they look in shorts but leggings
nice leggings can make you look a lot
back
I know that's true but but okay so I'm
not gonna ask how I mean I've never won
leggings have never worn scars so I have
no idea what the relative comfort of
these clothing items is our leggings
significantly more comfortable than
skirts you don't wear a skirt to the
grocery store going on a walk you want
called athleisure so it's athletic so
you can go from working out to the
grocery store I used to teach bar and so
that's really all that I wore is legging
so it's very hard for me to see them as
inappropriate although I will say I get
the argument of course my Christian
friends my brothers in Christ have told
me you know what this is inappropriate
it's a modest but okay when your
daughter is 16 are you gonna let her go
to school in leggings no I'm not letting
her leave the house that's okay my
question is there are ways to make
leggings more more modest so what if you
had like a longer shirt or something
that's different that's different yeah I
mean like stuff that clings to the
calves is inherently what a lot of
people would say obviously wearing a
tube top and leggings is a totally
different which is I think where the
that's the part of this story that's
totally overlooked is that the woman who
originally brought the reason this has
come up is because there's this woman
who wrote a letter to the editor at
Notre Dame and she wrote this letter
about these girls who wore leggings and
and tank tops to mass yeah on a Sunday
and she said that was inappropriate and
then people at Notre Dame went crazy how
could you tell young girls not to wear
leggings to church on a Sunday yeah and
because that's that's imposing your
value system on his girls and I just
thought to myself wait a second I
wouldn't you know I went to a private
Jewish day school where we had separate
girls and boys schools which by the way
highly recommended very good idea
because it was actually statistically
underperform when they are in high
school classes with boys they
purposefully underperform because they
think that guys are attracted to girls
who underperformed statistics yeah so
there's that and we all had school
uniforms and that was a very good thing
to have school uniforms because there is
a competitive a competitiveness to dress
particularly among girls that does not
exist when there is school uniforms now
this is not a case that across the broad
spectrum of society that everyone has to
wear a uniform or anything like that but
it doesn't seem to me that there's been
a generalized acceptance of dressing
down to the point where a modesty is
is basically seen as something not only
normal but praiseworthy like you're more
courageous the less modest you are yeah
the less modest you are publicly and
this applies to guys too by the way like
when I see guys running around on the
street in just shorts and no shirt and
I'm like just put on a shirt dude yeah
what is this yeah and girls I mean
basically do the same thing as well and
now I do think that there are settings
in which certain clothes are appropriate
and settings in which certain clothes
are inappropriate I would say church is
an inappropriate place to wear leggings
because they're too casual but see the
grocery store when you got two kids in
tow and you don't want to wear shorts or
a skirt as you would suggest then I
think you look at me Lauren when you a
skirt what no but I understand I
understand that your concerns
I'll think about this and you can wear
whatever you want but this this one
again falls under the the matrix of
reality which is if it that you can you
can wear whatever you want I got it it's
fine it's a free country wear whatever
you want not saying that you can't I'm
not saying if a guy does something bad
or stairs you do it the wrong way that
that is that that is acceptable in any
way paint it too modest but I'm saying
it is less modest on an objective
standard than the vast majority of
clothing that women publicly because you
can see I mean it depends on the length
of the shorts so you're good with
Bermuda shorts and skirts got it jeans
are fine like I mean I don't listen
again wear whatever you want but they
but on the on the hierarchy but this is
the part of the debate that I find so
like you're you're making an argument
that is based on comfort but part that
the debate that I actually stop publicly
was not about that debate I saw publicly
was I can wear whatever I want and it's
not my fault how guys look at me and I
just thought like well true and not true
like true that guys are not relieved of
responsibility and how they oh go women
also not true in that how you dress
obviously has an impact on how people
look at you I mean if that were not the
case then policemen were not wear
uniforms and doctors were not wear white
clothes yeah and I totally agree with
you so maybe there is a little bit of
hypocrisy on my side because I agree
with that I totally agree with that and
I agree with modesty and I agree with
personal responsibility we just talked
about it
really love leggings but I'll think
about it I'll think about this on mold
is over I a lot of leg games to get rid
of that's like half my clock I mean your
husband's then on the show how is your
husband and thumbs up or thumbs down on
the leggings
he's thumbs up on the leggings for her
or for just generally just for her
exactly that's right other women thumbs
up or thumbs down thumbs down correct
gives a different answer he's in trouble
I don't want that yeah everything
everything else is fine okay so with all
of that said let's move back to more
serious politics who do you think is the
frontrunner for the Democratic
nomination mentioned Kamala Harris do
you think that she is the front-runner
at this but no I don't think she's a
front-runner I think probably Bernie
Sanders right isn't that's where the
numbers are right now Bernie Sanders I
don't think that Beddoe has a chance I
thought that he might be a stronger
contender when he first announced I just
don't think he's enough specificity and
his platform I think that I mean I guess
I think Bernie Sanders I also didn't
think that he was going to be a strong
contender because because he has these
ideas that are now promulgated by other
people who are more intersectional than
he is and so why would he still why
would he still have so much sway but
apparently he does he's the og the og
socialist so my theory is that he's
gonna run the Trump 2016 campaign that
effectively he's got something between
25 and 30 percent of the vote
everybody attacks Biden goes after the
Jeb Bush in the race that he just sits
there 25 to 30 percent everybody else
splits the rest of the vote he wins the
first couple of primaries at 25 and 30
that starts ticking up to 35 and 40 and
suddenly he's sweeping through
California New York and Massachusetts
which is where most of the delegates are
I think right now legitimately he's got
to be the favorite which is kind of
frightening what do you that an
octogenarian socialist who used to root
openly for the Soviet Union thought that
bread lines were good because at the end
of them was bread what do you think it
says about the country that this person
is the frontrunner well I think it means
that Millennials which are almost the
largest voting bloc I don't think they
will be I think baby boomer still
eclipses them a little bit but I think
it means that Millennials have more sway
and more of a voice and that's where
Millennials are that's where the number
is that's where the numbers show us
going that we are okay with socialism
were warmed to socialism
we are completely fine with the idea of
nice Anders and the idea of even a
president AOC one day and I think it
speaks a lot to how little we know about
history and how little we actually know
about economics but also that we just
want we just want someone who we see as
an anti-trump and in some ways bernie is
simply because he's anti-american anti
what makes America great anti capitalism
anti all of the things that policy-wise
Trump has stood for and so I think
people are down for that but also they
still want to be a little bit
comfortable so they got to pick the
white male let's let's talk about how we
reach out to young people so obviously
you are the conservative millennial
which means that you have a unique
capacity to draw the youths so well what
is it what is the way that that
conservatives should look to appealing
to young people the way the way that I
see older people thinking the younger
people should appeal to is completely
fruitless to me and they they're
constantly saying things like why don't
you just talk to eighteen year olds
about Social Security and solvency and I
think great idea fantastic there's
nothing eighteen year olds want to talk
about more than when they're 65 and
ready for retirement yeah yeah 2100 yeah
well I started out as the conservative
millennial and then I kind of moved away
from that only because like when I first
had the name the conservative millennial
it seemed like much more of a paradox
than it is now there's been a lot of
voices obviously you existed far beyond
when I started but there's been a lot of
voices that have picked up steam and
have gained a lot of traction over the
past few years that being a conservative
millennial now I feel like is not as
crazy as it used to be even you even
though you're a famous far before 2015
in the past few years like your star has
risen so much to where everyone knows
okay at least one conservative
millennial exists and so I kind of moved
away from that and moved more into just
talking about the things that I really
believe in which is not just politics
not just Donald Trump but really how
faith affects what you think about
politics and what you think about
culture and finding that intersection
has been not only fun but also rewarding
because what I've realized is that a lot
of young people really want to know
truth and they're really interested in
the meaning of life they're really
interested in purpose and they just
don't know what it is they're kind of
just a you know
just writing on these waves of life
trying to figure it all out but what I
found is that they're actually really
curious to know why they should believe
a certain thing I don't think they're
given that great of an answer on the
left for why they should believe those
things how does that attach to a
particular value or a set of principles
and I think on the right we have an
opportunity to say okay here's why we
believe what we believe here's the value
system that this connects to
particularly for like Christian women
because Christian women can be swayed by
the emotionalism of the left but to say
okay well here's why I'm a conservative
and here's where actually in the Bible I
find the foundation for these kind of
principles there's a space there and I
think it's open for people like you and
me to speak into and people are hungry
for that so when you talk about theology
where do you tend to start you tend to
start with the Bible do you tend to
start with faith-based arguments do you
use rationality to get to the
faith-based arguments where does that
conversation begin I don't have to do
that I don't with my podcast I don't
have to start necessarily with
rationality and back up from there it
depends if I'm talking about a news
story or I'm talking about a culture
story of course I talk through the facts
and and what is actually going on and
then you can kind of back up and give a
theological basis for why you're seeing
this issue a particular way but I have
one podcast dedicated every week to
theology and those I assume that the
people listening to me are Christians
and what I found is that they are those
are definitely my most popular podcasts
where I only talk about a biblical issue
or maybe how it relates to the culture
how a cultural issue is related to the
Bible and what I found again is that
there's just not a lot of particularly
women who talk about the Bible in a way
that says this is real this is true this
is the standard to which we're supposed
to live up to it's more romantic
feel-good Jesus is here to tell you this
you look really pretty kind of stuff and
I think that there are women who were
thirsty for real truth in real knowledge
and so all I have to do is support my
theological views with the Bible you
don't have to go outside of that it's
self affirming so what are your core
theological views when what branch of
Christianity do you belong to and what
are the kind of core beliefs yes so I am
what you would call a reformed
Protestant and I within that I am a
Calvinist and so Cal
has it's called tulip it's total
depravity unconditional election limited
atonement oh gosh what's IPAs
perseverance of the states oh and I is
irresistible grace and so basically what
that means it's a very contentious view
in some ways especially to my Catholic
friends that we that God chose who he is
going to save in Christ before the
foundation of the world where we get
that as Romans 9 and other text that you
are predestined by God to be saved and
you live out your faith once you are
chosen basically this idea of
irresistible grace that you didn't
actually do it I think I heard Matt
Walsh say that you know faith is like a
bridge and you actually have to walk
over it while Calvinists wouldn't say
that a Calvinist would say that well no
Jesus came down picked you up cleaned
you off and walked you over to the other
side to God so there is no I earned it
myself I mean Ephesians 2 talks about
that a lot that it's not our own doing
it is by grace and so that's where I
land Protestant Calvinists and there's a
lot of young people that have really
kind of joined that movement since
probably 2008 there's no responsibility
and free will fit into that view yeah
it's well the same thing with Jesus said
a tree will be known by its fruit and we
the Bible is filled with directives the
New Testament is filled with directives
the epistles by Paul are filled with
directives things that we are supposed
to do we are supposed to align our lives
with Christ because of our salvation
Ephesians 2 says that we were dead in
our sins but we were saved by grace it's
not your own doing so that no man can
boast and so I think that's pretty clear
that it wasn't our own doing for
salvation but because we were saved by
Christ we kind of live up to that
salvation through something called
sanctification which is the pursuit of
holiness and the pursuit of a righteous
life which does include all the things
that a lot of the things that you
believe in which not the cleansing laws
but a lot of the moral laws which is
giving to the poor and helping your
community and living a life that mirrors
Christ so are you choosing to do that or
is that just something that you are
already going to do and you're basically
kind of just living it out so there is a
balance that I think a lot of people get
confused on when you hear Calvinists you
hear preordained you think oh well you
don't believe
even any freewill at all and that's not
true now I will say there is what kind
of seems like a conundrum or a conflict
between personal responsibility and
absolute sovereignty of God so we
believe that God is absolutely sovereign
over everything there is no point
whatsoever where he sits back and he
just lets things happen or says oh
whoops like I didn't see that coming we
believe in the absolute sovereignty of
God over everything and yet the Bible is
very clear that people have personal
responsibility and that the Christians
believe if you don't accept Christ which
accept is kind of a word that we don't
really use in Calvinism but that there
is punishment there's eternal punishment
from that therefore that there's eternal
separation from God and so you are held
to the consequences of your sin to the
consequences of the life that you live
and yet God is sovereign over all of
that
sadi how do you square that circle you
square that circle with Romans 9 that
says that that asks that very question
and so the Romans were asking that
question okay well how can God find
fault if he Destin's people to hell if
he says that you were going to be
separated for me forever why would God
create anyone like that knowing that
they're gonna spend eternity without him
and Paul answers that with another
question he says well the clay say to
the Potter why did you make me this way
God is going to harden whom He wills and
He will have mercy on whom he wells the
same way that he hardened the same way
that he hardened Pharaoh that is God's
will he is sovereign and who are we to
ask God whether or not he is just God
does the things that he does that are
higher than our ways and higher than our
thoughts and that's something that I
don't think any Calvinist pretends to
understand or anyone or anyone who reads
Romans 9 pretends to understand why
would God create what Romans nine calls
vessels of Wrath and vessels of mercy
and the answer really is for his own
glory so how do you how do you create by
into the systems of theology you're
preaching me you say the in this
particular podcast that you do you
assume that people are coming because
they already have a certain level of
buy-in but are you attempting to kind of
speak to those people and then deepen
their knowledge or you're attempting to
kind of broaden out the siphon from what
you're drawing folks what I want people
to do is to rely on the supremacy and
the authority of Scripture rather than
your feelings so we hear a lot
culturally Christian messages that are
really popular the whole you are enough
thing or if you do this God is going to
bless you God wants you to be happy he
wants you to live this successful life
and chase after all of your dreams so
I'll take a cultural lie that we're
hearing and I'll say well okay this is
coming from a Christian teenager but
here's what the Bible says and if you're
a Christian teacher who doesn't believe
in the supremacy of Scripture why are
you a Christian teacher just be you know
just be a self-help guide just be a
motivational speaker but if we're
Christians then we need to hold you the
supremacy of Scripture because that's
the only God inspired Word that we have
and so why would we succumb to any other
Authority especially a secular Authority
so a lot of young people just they don't
know how to weigh the popular culturally
Christian messages against what the
Bible says and so that's what I try to
do just say well here's what the Bible
says okay so how do you what laws of
interpretive reason do you use when
applying the biblical text so I'm sure
you get the question a lot that the
Bible doesn't openly forbid slavery for
example so what laws of interpretation
do use in Judaism with this long oral
tradition constant reinterpretation of
the biblical text with an attempt to
good faith adhere to the fundamental
basis of the text what you're talking
about
how does it shade not into
fundamentalism to the point where no
reason can be applied at all or there
can't be yeah how would you separate out
the slavery question for example yeah so
a really good question that I've heard
or a really good statement that I've
heard is that when you're reading in the
Bible as a Christian you don't ask what
does this mean to you about what does
this mean period and so that means you
do look at the cultural context it does
mean that you do look at what kind of
literary device is being used obviously
hyperbole is sometimes used obviously
metaphor is sometimes used but it's
important to know when that is and when
that's not and when we are supposed to
take things literally and when we're
supposed to take things as hyperbole
like there is an open conversation about
the creation account and whether that
was a literal 24 24 hour day for six
days of creation or whether it wasn't
there are conversations within that as
long as we say that the biblical text is
our supreme authority not tradition not
church leaders not our own ideas or our
own feelings or what cold
culture says this cool right now but
what the scripture actually says you can
look at it in the original Hebrew and
the original Greek you can look at the
historical context and that's kind of
the the reason the interpretive reason
that you have to that you have to use to
decide okay what does this text actually
mean now it doesn't what does it mean to
me or what do I want it to mean but what
does it actually mean giving given the
context and given the original language
okay so how do you bring people who
aren't necessarily interested in the
text into the moral fold so how do you
make the argument to a secular person
that what you're talking about right now
is relevant to the lives or useful well
if I were to do that I don't do that
very often because what I found is that
people who listened to my podcast and
the messages that I've got from people
who say wow I didn't think this way
before but I do I've never really had to
make that kind of argument from a
secular perspective and then go into the
Bible I do think that's important to do
that's not particularly what I do on my
podcast but of course you can start from
this place of morality that everyone has
this sense of morality the sense of
right and wrong that no one is a true
moral relativist that no one believes in
relative truth people who say that
there's no absolute truth know that
absolutely so that is a whole conundrum
so you could start there and say okay
well if you acknowledge there is a right
and wrong that for example Hitler was an
evil person and that it's not just
culturally relative then you have to ask
yourself well where does that come from
where does truth come from it's the
whole it's the whole argument that CS
Lewis makes a mere Christianity about
the moral lawgiver if you believe in
some kind of moral law then you have to
ask yourself where does it come from it
can't come from the government that's
made by them it has to come from at
least some kind of transcendent
force or transcendent source and so you
could always go there so what is the
role of government in all of this so
you're preaching yeah obviously a pretty
heavy theology that assumes certain
moral boundaries what is the role of
government in imposing those moral
boundaries I think that Protestants have
typically said we want the role of the
government to be small and to basically
to leave us alone
we don't believe obviously in a
theocracy but we do believe that America
of course was built on Christian values
on the idea of the value of the
individual of the radical equality of
the individual the values of the
Protestant Reformation that
we saw a free inquiry being able to
study God's Word for yourself which of
course a lot of people say created a lot
of division but freedom always does and
so based America is based on those
values and we believe that those
principles are good for everyone not
just Christians but for people of every
faith so basically that's what we want
we want people to be free and we do
believe of course that people are better
bridled by religion and by morality but
it's pretty clear throughout history and
throughout the Bible that theocracies
don't work very well and I think that's
probably where a lot of evangelical
Christians land it does get muddy when
you talk to evangelicals about gay
marriage and when you talk to them about
things like that it's like it's really
hard to vote against your own personal
values if you feel like you need to vote
against your own personal values but
ultimately I do think that most
evangelical Christians just want the
government to leave us alone and to
protect our Liberty so where do you
stand on the the governmentally imposed
standard of marriage well I think like a
lot of Christians and maybe just a lot
of people of faith in general I wasn't
excited about the obergefell decision I
mean the thought is is that God created
marriage and he created marriage between
a man and a woman end of story but when
you realize that ok well the
government's decision they don't follow
God's standards for things necessarily
they don't follow God's definitions of
things necessarily and so if they're
going to have a separate definition of
marriage than what God says that's fine
but leave the churches alone if we
believe that God defined marriage then
we should be able to say whether or not
you know we want to marry two men or
marry two women and of course that's
protected for now and I think that's
where most people have graduated to I
think back in 2015 obergefell I think
happened I think a lot of people were
upset I mean we thought that it was
going to be the complete downfall of the
country and more people now we're like
ok just just leave our communities of
faith alone and let us make these
decisions
Megara worries that it won't be left
alone is that Alberta ought to be used
by the state governments to cram down
their viewpoints on churches and
synagogues and religiously owned
businesses I think we're already
thinking of that right yeah I agree with
you because they said that well this is
a right of of all people and if it's a
ratable people well then our church is
allowed
deny that don't know okay so I do have
one final question for you I want to ask
what your greatest worry is for your
baby because your baby's gonna be coming
soon with okay yeah so I'll ask you
about that and one second first if you
want to hear Ali Stuckey's answer you
have to be a daily water subscriber
subscribe head on over to daily we're
calm click Subscribe and you can hear
the end of our conversation over there
Ellie Stuckey of blase du Vieux thanks
so much for stopping by and good luck
baby thank you very much eventually row
shows Sunday special is produced by
Jonathan hey executive producer Jeremy
boring associate producer Mathis clever
edited by Donovan Fowler audio is mixed
by Dylan Kate's hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera title graphics by Cynthia
and gulo the Ben Shapiro show Sunday
special is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
[Music]